okay so things haven't gone our way yet
but we can turn it around it's a long Ro
ahead and golly it's already the quarter
season Carnival I want that
prize Josh get in the tank we'll find
someone who
will never Josh dos to the
move yeah let me get one coming right up
total accident
dude rich just saying coach maybe you
don't ride with Zach this time guys he's
right here ow it hurts my teeth let's
see can't with anyone too good or might
upset Aaron can't ride with anyone
terrible or my locker room will kill me
oh my God he's
perfect coach coach attention will
whoever is in charge of Kyle pits please
report to the lost and found he's been
here for like 3 years Amanda Amber Amy
who did that sorry coach told me to
throw
the my comments about coaching
missr man I can't win yeah that's the
whole problem on my
count he can't keep getting away with it
even though I know we're going to fall
it's still a surprise every time wait
where are you going I'm not sure we ever
drop please stay seated for the duration
of Tunnel of Love It ain't over until I
say it is I thought this ride was
supposed to be scary SMH I'm out oh hell
yeah we're going gol the rails baby oh
no I dropped it but you held on to it
for a long time though
[Music]
pal attention please stop using the
Giants line as a Turn Style use the
actual Park entrance this is your
minutely reminder that Taylor Swift is
here okay back to your little games
Jonathan Taylor please report to the
Colts n I'm
good